it's tempting to say that justice was
done on friday when the verdict in the
kyle written house trial was returned
and kyle was found not guilty on all
counts
it was certainly a just verdict the
right verdict but we can't say that
justice was done unless and until all of
the people responsible for this
political show trial are held
accountable the prosecutor should be
disbarred the media who smeared kyle as
a white supremacist serial killer should
be sued into bankruptcy their lives
should be ruined
they should suffer
we should want them to suffer for it
because that's justice
and that still would not even the score
it wouldn't set everything right because
they have taken something from kyle
rittenhouse that he can never get back
namely his entire normal life the life
he ought to have lived is gone
he is free as he should be but he'll
never really be free from the slander
and defamation that's what makes slander
and defamation so insidious
he'll have to walk around with the
scarlet r racist on his head forever
because that's the reality that the
media has constructed for him
and this is why they should pay and pay
dearly
it's not a no harm no foul situation
they have done immense harm to kyle
rittenhouse and done it on purpose with
malice in their hearts
and they aren't done after the verdict
was right on friday the the demons in
the corporate media convulsed and
screamed and vomited like a scene
straight out of the exorcist
watching msnbc on friday as i did for a
couple of hours purely for the
entertainment i have expected to see
someone's head do a like 360 degree turn
they were apoplectic in their demonic
rage and they were not prepared to
surrender their narrative or back away
from it even an inch
many examples of course we could play
for you you've probably seen a lot of
them but we'll settle on just a couple
first here's uh one of the hobgoblins on
msnbc tiffany cross
having a rather ghoulish temper tantrum
watch
i find these people disgusting ellie i'm
disgusted at what i'm seeing it's not
just this trial it's other trials but
this in particular the fact that white
supremacists roam the halls of congress
freely and celebrate this little
murderous white supremacist and the fact
that he gets to walk the streets freely
it lets you know these people have
access to instituting uh laws they
represent the legislative branch of this
country what are we to make of that
welcome to the modern republican party
this is what these people want and this
is what a majority of white people vote
for right when i say that a majority of
white people are in favor of this kind
of violence it is because a majority of
white people consistently vote
republican consider you know since the
passage of the civil rights act a
majority of white people have voted
republican right so like this is the
party that they're supporting a majority
of white people pick judges like bruce
schrader the judge in the cal written
house case a majority of white people do
not support policies that would unpack
and unroll and reform this system of
justice this is what they want matt
gates is giving the white folks what
they want look at it
look at yourselves
it's gross
but until a majority of you
stop voting for this
this will keep happening
i may have misheard it but did he snort
like a pig there
i don't know it's i mean if it oinks
like a pig you know what they say
little murderous white supremacist
is what uh kyle rittenhouse is called
there after the verdict he was found not
guilty of murder and he's not a white
supremacist there was never any reason
to think that he was a white supremacist
there's never been even one single
slight shred of evidence that he's a
white supremacist he shot three white
people in self-defense as the court of
law just declared by the way a majority
of white people are in favor of this
kind of violence i don't know where he's
getting this from but i'll tell you as
one white person yeah you're damn right
i am in favor
of violence in self-defense where you're
killing a child rapist who's trying to
kill you i'm in favor of that violence
all day every day
but msnbc will stick with the fantasy
scenario it constructed early on the
people at msnbc and across the corporate
media and the american left they arrived
at a conclusion about the written house
case within three minutes of the last
shot being fired
and they have not wavered from it even
the smallest bit since that initial
moment
that's because the truth doesn't matter
at all we'll get back to that point in a
moment but first here's another example
somehow uh even more delusional
this is someone named amber ruffin who
has some kind of show on msnbc or
peacock or whatever uh here she is
you guys because i have my own show i
have a responsibility to say things that
people need to know
that aren't being said
it's a cool opportunity that i don't
take lightly there are very big
obvious truths that no one wants to say
on tv but i will
now just a few minutes before we started
taping the show kyle rittenhouse the man
accused of shooting three people during
a black lives matter protest was
declared
not guilty on all charges so
i can't believe i have to say this but
it's not okay
for a man to grab a rifle
travel across state lines
and shoot three people and then walk
free
it's not okay for the judicial system to
be blatantly and obviously stacked
against people of color
it's not okay
for there to be an entirely different
set of rules for white people
state lines
i mean i get really emotional about
state lines also you travel across state
lines in fact i'm worried now
after the written house verdict that
this will set a precedent
and now people will feel
entitled to just cross state lines
whenever they want i i'm worried that
you know slippery slope situation that
that next thing you know we're going to
have a whole a system of roads set up
like like um maybe we need like an
interstate highway system they might
build where people just cross state
lines whenever they want that's what i'm
worried about
by the way um you know how kyle right
house was accused of crocodile tears
because he was uh he was uh he you know
had he had an emotional breakdown while
on trial to trying to save his life
um those were not crocodile tears if you
want to know what crocodile tears look
like which is what you just saw there
amber ruffin that's what that's what
fake crying looks like
and literally every single thing she
said
is wrong every word
starting with the pretense that what she
said there was somehow bold and brave
and something that nobody else is
willing to say
she simply repeated the same thing that
everyone in corporate media is saying
and has said a million times already yet
pretends that this requires courage
that nobody's going to say this
except the last seven million people you
heard say it so i'll say it
no courage and shamelessness are not the
same amber though i realize this
distinction is often lost on the left
she also says that he grabbed a rifle
and crossed state lines and murdered
people none of that is true
we know that it's not true
the facts are incontrovertibly against
her but what does she care
as for the justice system being stacked
against people of color
that seems an odd claim given that
nobody involved in this case was a
person of color black people have
nothing to do with this case
i understand that black supremacists
might struggle to understand that point
but it has nothing to do this this was a
case involving white people
is it true that only white murder
defendants get off on self-defense
claims
well no in fact on the very same day on
friday at almost the exact same time
that kyle rittenhouse was acquitted of
his murder charges on the basis of
self-defense
a man down in florida andrew coffey
was also found not guilty of murder and
attempted murder on the grounds of
self-defense after shooting at a swat
team that came into his house
unannounced
that acquittal was again on the same day
andrew coffey is black
on the same day
he's not alone amy swearer a legal
fellow at heritage has a great thread on
twitter documenting many recent cases of
black defendants being acquitted of
murder charges on the grounds of
self-defense it happens all the time it
is very very common
the media might not tell you about it
but it happens
there is simply no evidence at all no
reason to believe at all
that kyle rittenhouse would have been
convicted if he was black
there is no evidence at all no reason to
believe at all that self-defense laws
disproportionately help white people
there is no data to back that up none
in fact the opposite is probably the
case the daily caller ran an analysis um
back in 2013 in florida
to see who benefits the most from the
state's standard ground law
and they discovered that black people
are disproportionate beneficiaries of
that law
okay black person in florida is more
likely to be acquitted on self-defense
than a white person
and there's plenty of reason to believe
that this trend holds true across the
nation
but that won't stop the narrative or
even slow it down
just as the left has not held itself
back from anointing joseph rosenbaum and
anthony huber martyrs for the case
even as a court of law just effectively
found them both to be attempted
murderers i mean that's the
implication here if it was self-defense
on written houses side
then it was attempted murder on their
side
and that's the most flattering thing on
their resumes rosenbaum as you know from
the show was a serial child rapist a
pedophile sodomite who anally raped
young boys
yet protesters took to the street after
the verdict and chanted rosenbaum's name
listen to this
say his name joseph rosenbaum
that's almost as sickening as the
tributes that have poured in from
hollywood actor pedro
pascal tweeted joseph rosenbaum 36 and
anthony huber 27 murdered august 25th
2020.
rest in peace
now the best i can say about that
statement
is that it's a bit optimistic
rosenbaum a serial child rapist who died
while trying to kill a teenage boy is
almost certainly burning in hell
you know that say his name joseph
rosenbaum we can imagine the legions in
hell that's what greeted
uh rosenbaum as he was walking
down the hallway
god's forgiveness of course knows no
bounds but considering his last moment
on earth was spent trying to murder a
teenager it seems unlikely that he had
any sort of last-minute repentance or
conversion meanwhile mark ruffalo
tweeted
quote we come together to mourn the
lives lost to the same racist system
that devalues black lives and devalued
the lives of anthony and jojo
hashtag reimagine kenosha
yes
that's a major hollywood actor using a
cutesy pet name for a serial child
rapist
talk about saying the quiet part out
loud
i mean these hollywood perverts are so
used to hanging out with child molesters
and rapists that they feel bonds of
affection even with the rapists they've
never met
so perhaps i assume too much for all i
know rosenbaum and ruffalo went to the
same parties who knows
either way add rosenbaum to the list of
recent heroes and martyrs of the left
it's a list that includes george floyd
a man who forced his way into a woman's
home and robbed her at gunpoint
blake a violent felon an alleged rapist
and woman abuser who assaulted police
brandished a knife
got shot while trying to steal a car and
kidnap children
rayshard brooks a felon who passed out
drunk at a fast food drive-through lane
then got himself shot while fighting
with the cops and stealing their taser
dante wright a wanted criminal who
sexually assaulted a woman and robbed
her at gunpoint
now now to this pantheon this mount
rushmore of deviants and demons we can
add joseph rosenbaum child molester and
rapist
these are the men that the left bids us
to celebrate and admire
the absolute worst source of people
human society has to offer
the dregs of humanity
the bottom of the barrel these are meant
to be our our martyrs
so what's going on here between the
celebration of joseph rosenbaum all of
the lies told about kyle rittenhouse
what we have to understand is that the
left is not just building a narrative
though they are doing that
but more so they're creating an entire
new reality
their ultimate goal is to construct an
alternate
universe
you know i give a talk on college
campuses called the war on reality about
the left's efforts to redefine life
marriage and gender and the title is not
hyperbole
i mean they have waged war on reality
itself truth itself
and as i argue in the talk the three
main pillars of this effort the three
primary modes of attack are to redefine
these fundamental elements of human
civilization
their battle plan has been such a
success thus far that many people in our
society today will look you in the eyes
and flatly deny that any such thing as
truth or objective reality exists
the upshot is that with something like
the written house verdict
it's fruitless to argue that the left's
narrative isn't true or that it
contradicts the facts they know that and
they don't care or i should say
contradicting the facts is the whole
point
telling a leftist that their claims
about some event are untrue it's like
reading a sci-fi novel and objecting
that none of that happened in real life
it's a fantasy
well yeah that's the point
the only difference between the sci-fi
novel and the claims made by the leftist
is that the fictional reality in the
book is supposed to be contained only in
the book for the leftist we're all meant
to live in his fictional reality
we're supposed to pretend that it's real
a world governed by self-identity and
emotional whim a reality that is
malleable
which changes to accommodate political
and ideological needs
that's the objective
that's what's at stake
and it's time we understand
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends